(piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical eight.
Bipedal, naked, large brain.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize, and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(new age music)
- Pretty extraordinary kind of range
of work that I think we've seen
and in the way in which
these ideas kind of layer onto each other.
You know I think it was really incredible
when we were seeing the Kennis brothers
and you know...
You start to hear the kinds of,
the depth and complexity that is brought
to the idea of how you could go about
building a reconstruction
and you recognize that they are not only
kind of just looking at trying to come up
with a certain kind of physical fidelity
based on best practices
but that involves the development
and thinking about all
the other kind of factors
that would go into you know
what an early human or
other kind of hominid life
might actually consist of
and then how the kind
of aesthetic criteria
goes into creating
something that can actually
engage our imagination as we look at it.
And in all the work that I
think we've heard about today,
recognizing the necessity to be able
to think actually very
broadly across disciplines
such that you know
taking on a question like
you know the human origins,
you might come at it
from a disciplinary expertise
but because you're entering into such
unknown territory, you know the vectors
that you try to connect that are beyond
the specifics that you
bring to the question
are the ones that possibly lead you
to new kinds of answers about it.
And so I hope everybody, people have been
filling out the questionnaires
and handing them to
to the edges of the
aisles where our trusty
helpers here are kind of gathering them
and now I think we're
gonna do some Q and A
and so Allyson's gonna start.
- Alright, I've been collecting
the questions for the first part and...
So the first question is for Caren.
So the question is how do you feel about
pressure on teachers in
elementary school grades,
K, transitional K fours to eliminate
playing class and emphasize academics.
I think you have to come here.
- Hi, good question, right?
So this is very much a
question that's being posed
to developmental psychologists
today all the time, right.
There's all these new sort
of academic pressures,
things are sort of getting
pushed earlier and earlier,
there's less and less time for sort of
free and exploratory activities,
much more time spent on test preparation.
I don't think that anyone would say
that this is a good idea per se.
I mean I think that what we have seen
is that at least in the early school years
so in preschool in particular.
Preschools have completely adopted
a play focused emphasis.
To you this probably
seems totally natural now
because this is just the
way that we live our lives,
we just assume that play
is precisely the work
of this early childhood
and I think that now
with the sort of new
science that's coming out
showing that playful learning
actually might continue
right to have these sorts of benefits
and even later on,
there's pressure being put
on the education system to sort of combat
the direction that we've gone in
which is the sort of college preparation
that starts even as early as first grade
so it's bad.
(laughter)
But it's hard, right, it's
a really difficult problem
and I do think that right now
it's part of the conversation and so it's
certainly going to be adjusting.
- I have another one for you.
So you said evidence of imagination
can be seen as soon as infants can speak.
Does neo natal imitation suggest
that newborns imagine the
existence of other people.
- Sorry.
Neo natal imitation does it suggest
that they're imagining other people,
I don't have an answer to that question.
I don't know, I can't even
speculate on that question
in fact, I'm not sure.
So I think that generally what we think of
as neo natal movements right
there's an interaction
between touch sensation
from the mother and neo natal movement
also to sound right, and other kinds
of sensory inputs so
they're reacting, right
in many ways to their tactile
and sensory environment
but I don't think that we can speculate
about imagination.
We know that neonates learn right
so they can be exposed to
particular kinds of sounds
for example in utero and afterwards
show signs of recognizing those sounds
in various learning contacts
there's some really
interesting and ingenious
ways of testing this, they also recognize
the smell of fluids that were
taken from the mother as well
and so there's recognition
and there's learning
that happens neonatally but I don't know
I can't comment on imagination.
- So I'll just take
advantage that you are here,
I'll ask you another one.
How does a child
counterfactual cognition change
as he or she acquires language?
- How does counterfactual cognition change
as they acquire language, right.
So, it makes sense right that being able
to think about alternative possibilities
should be influenced by
having abstract concepts
and language gives us
those abstract concepts
so as we acquire more
rich and complex language
we're also able to think of more
rich and complex kinds
of narratives, right
and so this in part probably explains
some of the developmental
changes that we see
from very very early sort
of proto kinds of pretense
which is mostly just substitute
one object for another
to the very elaborate kinds
of pretense that we see
in middle childhood and adolescence
where they're developing these societies
that have their own system of governance
and rules and food and clothing
I mean it's really
amazing the work out there
sort of documenting middle childhood
and the kinds of
paracosms that they create
and those things are dependent of course
on a more mature language
and so it seems to me
that there's a relationship there.
- Okay, I think that's all for you.
- Okay, thank you guys so much.
- Sheldon.
(applause)
So I have a couple for Sheldon.
Why do people have different
levels of imagination?
- Well you know there's certainly a lot
that might have that is attributable
to the cultural and social
upbringing and pressures.
Whether or not there're underlying
neurological differences
that's maybe too murky
a thing that we haven't
been able to explore yet
but you know so in a lot
of educational theory
that educational theories
are changing always
and evolving and culturally you see
these differences where some children
are encouraged to imagine more
and for longer periods of time
and in other cultures you know it's like
childhood's over, get to work, you know
kind of attitudes
and so some of this
kind of spills over into
life in general as it's lived in adulthood
but even in those cases
you certainly always
have a kind of counter, you know
counter examples of people who seem
to go against the grain and
have this kind of ongoing
imaginative capacity and you know
so then sometimes there
are these things like
you know where everyone's an artist,
everyone can do all this stuff
and you know and I think that's also
kind of an oversimplification
of the cognitive differences that we have.
So we're mentally very diverse species
and I think we should,
we really should celebrate that diversity
rather thank think that everybody
should be everything all the time.
- But if you take like
science fiction writers
from different cultures,
is there something unique about them?
- Well you certainly see that,
so he was asking if you
take science fiction writers
which is a group of imaginative people
that we spent some time talking with
and is there something
different about them.
Well I think one thing you see
is that there are different ways
in which they think about problems
and so there might be these kind of
practices that they have cultivated
or that they kind of
naturally kind of gravitated
to which caused them
to think about problems
in ways that are more orthogonal
to how those problems
are typically approached
and it often means they they're kind of
really expand the context by which
they place problems within
so they don't think of them
quite so instrumentally
from a singular perspective.
They are often kind of read across
many different kinds of literatures
or engage in many different
kinds of discourses
so historical, scientific,
you know humanistic,
a bunch of different kinds of things
and then the work that they do
comes up with a kind of original synthesis
out of those many different elements
and so you start to see those kinds
of characteristics and then
if the question is well
why do they have them, you know
that is a good question.
(laughs)
- So another one for you here.
So I think I'll simplify that but
is imagination really humans
is it present in different animals,
there are evidence that perhaps
chimpanzees even gorillas may have
some kind of imagination
and in this same context
what about artificial intelligence,
you can make a computer be creative
or have innovation, is it imagination?
- Yeah, so you know I kind of indicated
a little bit the
in my talk how much richer our theories
of imagination can become when we
consider the imaginative
realms of the non human
and you know and this
isn't to kind of diminish
the kind of unique
capabilities of homo sapiens
but I think we start to really expand
our understanding of our own imaginations
by trying to recognize what the kind of
imaginative umwelt is of
other kinds of entities.
You know I gave just some
kind of cheeky little examples
but you know to then consider
well what is the imagination
of a swarm of bees
and you know that has both
a kind of social dimension
as well as an individual dimension
is an interesting way to
kind of think about then
how does that relate to what we consider
our kind of social imagination.
And then as it goes to this question
of artificial intelligence that often,
as I mentioned a little bit,
when we start to approach the notion
of constructing an artificial intelligence
we do so by thinking of it
as modeling aspects of human intelligence
or human imagination.
Well our models of that,
our own understanding
of what we're trying to model
is very limited fragmented and emergent
and so to kind of think of that
as the kind of beginning and end
of what an artificial imagination could be
is a terrible limitation
on that possibility
and in fact what we might find
is the more kind of viable
artificial imagination
would be imagination that is as alien
to the human imagination as
that swarm of bees imagination
is to the human imagination.
So all of these things kind of you know
considering how we might.
We need to continuously expand
our conceptions of what this kind of
human phenomena is in relationship
to the rest of the biosphere
and the techno sphere
that we're in the process of building.
(applause)
- Agustín Fuentes, some questions for you.
That's an interesting one.
When it comes to
imagination why distinguish
stone chipped tools from a
branch of stripped leaves.
- So why, I have pockets
so I can use me hands there
I don't have to go like this.
What's the difference between stone tool,
chimpanzees will frequently,
different communities of chimpanzees
will take a branch, strip
that branch of leaves,
break it to an appropriate length
and then use it for fishing
for termites or a variety of other things.
Other chimpanzees will carry with them
a small stripped branch
that they really like,
they'll walk for 20
minutes to another site
where the termite den is,
pick up a stick there,
use that stick first
to modify the termite, then
use that secondary stick,
a work by Crickette
Sanz and her colleagues
have demonstrated that so there's a lot
of incredible and then there's other,
not just chimpanzees, crows
and a number of organisms that use sticks
and modified sticks in
a simple way for tools.
None of those require the level
of multiple foresight and planning
or structural and manual,
visual manipulation
that making stone tools does.
It's too bad I should've had just brought
some pieces of flint or
obsidian and shown you
because it's really hard for us to imagine
how many sequences in the future
and how radically,
especially for something
like an Acheulean tool
you have to envision iterative steps
and each time you have to re envision them
because you've changed the platform.
So there're many other examples
but the stone tool is a good one
because people have tried to teach
some of the smartest, most
human like chimpanzees
to make stone tools and we can't do it.
What we did learn, and
chimps are incredibly smart,
Kanzi we tried to teach,
people tried to teach
him how to make stone tools,
what Kanzi learned really quickly is that
we wanted him to make
some sharp edged rocks
so finally he went to the highest place
and started breaking all the rocks
and brought people edges
which is really smart, but
it's not creating stone tools.
- Have another one for you.
Given the expensive nature
of human imagination
of human imagination,
restructuring the environment,
notably accelerating species extinctions
and emerging technologies
is the end of the nature
as we have inherit inevitable?
- So let me back up one second and go back
to stone tools because one of the things
we have to think about is what's
called niche construction.
So this is humans are very very good
at dealing with the pressures of the world
by actually changing
those pressures, right
which then changes the way
we interface with the world
so rather than thinking of the environment
just affecting organisms,
think about organisms and environment
in a mutual advance, co shaping
and reshaping one another.
In the human context,
what we become especially
good at in the last, we've been doing this
for a couple million years
but in the last many thousand years,
let's say five to ten 15,000 years
we've become really really
good at re engineering,
reconstructing other
species and landscapes
for our own benefit.
Now that's had a lot of cascade effects
frequently when we change one component
in the environment, other components
come back to bite us in the butt.
And so we then reconfigure that
so this back and forth is what humans do
that's how we made it in the world.
Imagination plays a critical role in that.
Now, what we've found
in contemporary times
and we can go back and look at this
from any context, we
find that in many cases
humans exceed, manipulate
or erroneously assume
some manipulation is gonna
have a positive effect.
And we see humans correcting for that
but we also see lot's of human
populations going extinct.
Remember most human
populations for the history
of our genus have gone extinct.
Right, we now are doing something
we as humans and what we do,
we're causing one of the
largest extinction events
in the history of our planet
but we know that we're doing it.
Well we all know, most
people don't admit it.
But we also know what those processes are
so is it too late, no
no it's not too late.
It is not too late,
we're not gonna fall off
and break the world but we are breaking
many many many ecosystems
and so using imagination and using
this collaboration and compassion
and this ability to sort of think
both technologically and socially
through issues, we know as many problems
as we're causing ecologically
we also have the knowledge
to address a vast majority of those.
Do we have the will, do
we have the imagination
and do we have the endurance,
that's another question.
(applause)
- You should come, 'cause I see the time
and maybe you should
ask some from your pool.
- So question for Lera.
So are there any known
languages or cultures
that don't use metaphor?
- That's a really interesting question.
So languages of course
have a finite set of words
and we have an infinite set of
situations we want to talk about
so in fact there isn't a way
to avoid using metaphor
whenever you're talking
you're always going to be extending
prior uses of words in
slightly new contexts.
Some of those extensions will strike you
as more metaphorical, some will strike you
as more mundane but in fact
we're always stretching
and pushing the boundaries of language
and the way I think about
the dictionary is that it's basically
a retirement home for metaphors.
Right, once a metaphor has
gotten conventionalized enough
that you don't hear it
as a novel use anymore,
it kind of goes and retires
and becomes a meaning in the dictionary
but really you're always extending words.
One exercise I give to my students
is just to take any article
in the New York Times,
take the front page of the New York Times
and go through and try to underline
everything that's a metaphor
and it's really hard to
get through a sentence
without finding a metaphor
and once you start adding in spacial
prepositions like if someone
says it arrived on time
well that's a spacial word
that we're using for time,
is that a metaphor?
Once you start, once you
get caught up in that
you're basically underlining every word
in the New York Times as a metaphor
and it just gives you
that sense of how hard
it is to actually tell
what is the literal meaning
because you're always
using words in new contexts
and you're always pushing the boundaries,
that's the nature of language.
- Great, another question for you.
So in the work you've
been doing looking at time
have you looked at when children
start to have a sense of time
and if so is there anything about how
they map directions of time and space
before they learn reading
and writing for example?
- It's a wonderful question.
Of course there're many different things
that we mean by time, there's
a judgment of duration,
or a sense of duration but there are also
more abstract things like the idea
of tomorrow, now a word like tomorrow
is hard to learn because
you never see tomorrow,
people always talk about tomorrow
but not when tomorrow is around.
It's never around, right so how do you
figure out what that means,
it takes a little while.
So it does take kids a little while
to figure out these temporal terms.
Kids do start to organize things
according to the directions
that are prevalent in our culture
before they start reading
and writing themselves
and partially that's because of how much
their parents do that kind of
organizing for them, right.
So even if you yourself are not reading,
your parent is likely reading to you
and pointing things out to
you in a particular direction.
And all kinds of things in your household
are going to be arranged that way
and so there're going to be
all these cultural practices
that drive exploration
in a particular direction
from left to right.
You'll be asked to line up
in lines from left to right
and all kinds of other things
so that's a cultural
practice that permeates
lots and lots of other things
that then start to predate
reading and writing.
- Great, thank you.
Have some other questions.
(applause)
Got questions for Polly about
can you come on up?
So one thing you were starting to get to
at the end of your talk was looking at
arctic societies and
a question comes up about whether or not
they spend more time telling stories
within the long winter nights.
- First I want to--
- Talk into there.
- First I want to make a correction,
this is has nothing to do with pockets.
This is a picture from
the New Guinea highlands
where it's very cold in the morning
and this is what we call
the Highlands over coat.
(laughter)
That's what it is.
Anyway, yes in the arctic I've looked
through many arctic societies
and like the Tlingit,
they will tell stories
for three or four days going.
They will build fires
that are six feet high,
they will sit around and then in between,
they'll sleep a bit and they'll continue
for days on end so yes,
in those areas and of course
they also have very
elaborate social networks
to remember kinship systems
because there's very high risk
in the arctic, so yes.
- Okay, and then another question
any of the societies that you've looked at
utilize any neurochemical augmentation
as a part of their storytelling rituals?
- Okay, none of the
societies I've looked at do,
the bushmen go into trance
so actually when they're in trance
and sometimes they go into trance
when telling stories, it's completely
done without any
neurochemical augmentation
whatsoever and yet when
you see them in trance
some times they fall in the fire
and they're burning and
they don't even feel it
and then somebody else will say,
hey get your arm out of the fire
and so they really get
into a very very intense
altered state of consciousness,
it's very painful to go into this
but it's done without drugs.
There are a lot of
societies that use drugs too
but not usually with storytelling
unless a bit of marijuana.
- Thank you thank you.
(applause)
Allyson, couple questions for you.
And actually we have
a cluster of questions
that are somewhat related
and they have to do
with 23 and Me analyses
of people's DNA and coming back
and I'm nine percent
neanderthal and blah blah blah.
And so are you at the point
where you're able to look at
what this kind of latent
neanderthal DNA is
in humans and does any of that relate
to neurological development?
- Yeah, that's a great question
that was heavily discussed
in another Carta meeting
on genetic origins of the neanderthals.
So there's a fraction
of the human population,
most Europeans who actually
have the small part
of neanderthal genome.
And yeah companies like 23 and Me
have making claims that they can detect
the fraction or how much you have.
It's not a lot, it varies
between two and four percent
and everybody has is likely different,
it's not that everybody has the same
pieces of those, or fragments of those
neanderthal DNAs have been linked
to human conditions both
positive or negative
in right now I mean other than that
it's all very correlational,
there are some studies that are trying
to make a point for
why this was positively
selected in humans,
why we still have them
but I think experimental validation
such as recreating
these networks in a dish
even for all the tissues
is too in the early stages
so there is not much we can
say except for correlation.
- Okay, so
I guess another category of interest
has to do with things like
when you're working with
this kind of human origin work
and in a very wet way
with the actual genomes,
what kind of oversight is there
for this research or where,
what do you think are the,
kind of even the underlying ethics
of doing work with DNA and it maybe
not only applies to this work
but we can think of it
in a broader context of
you know everything that
we're now able to do
with Crisper technology
and the kinds of genetic engineering
that is viable now that is
just kind of extraordinary.
So what are your thoughts about that?
- So this is a very field
and especially for the brain
it always raises a
little bit more red flags
than on the tissue.
Nobody complains when
you make like a mini gut
in a dish but if you say
you have a mini brain,
people go oh, brain.
And so far we have been
away from any ethical
controversies mainly
because those mini brains
never show an activity level
similar to something like a human brain,
a baby most of the work
before what I showed
you has been doing that
by gene expression and
that's a little bit tricky
because you are always
compared to a postmortem brain
now that we're showing real activity
and are actually plugging that
into a robot or even in the other tissue
that can actually experience
the world that becomes a
little bit more problematic.
I think people are, and
scientists are aware
that these might create some
concerns in parts of the society
but nonetheless we are doing that
to answer from the mental questions
and my lab focuses on
neurological disorders
so the aim is good.
Same rationale could be applied
for genome editing, right?
We have now this possibility
to modify genomes
we can go to an embryo and fix
terrible mutation that that person
will have for the rest of his life
but what about if you start to using
this genome editing to create people
that are taller or have blue eyes
or are more intelligent if we figure out
what is the biological basis of that
so it's up to the society
to put the threshold.
In my experience I think most scientist
would agree with that, in the beginning
of a new technology there always
some turmoil about what
the consequences of that
but this is slowly will go away
as the scientist shows
how useful are those.
So the same thing for blood transfusion
for organ transplant,
they all raise red flags
and now we do it quite common to do it.
So I think the idea of brain
organize in genome editing
will pass through some kind of moratorium
and we'll know what's possible, what's not
what's dangerous, what's not
and we will regulate from there.
- Yeah it's great I think the
you know the work is in a state where it's
tremendously evocative you know
it's very novel for people to hear about
and then you put it in a robot, you know
and maybe the robot has like
lasers and buzz saws on it
or something and so that maybe
kind of raises some questions but
you know I think for all of this
it is this idea that you know
that we do bring our imaginations
and the work that everybody's doing
is kind of stimulating us
to kind of rethink what our humanity is,
what it consists of, where it's,
and when we try to think about where it's
coming from, it's definitely
with an idea to think
about where's it going.
And you know and we here many things
about this is how we see
imagination happening in childhood,
this is how we see it
happening in other species,
this is the kind of condition of humanity
that leads us to kind of have this genetic
and cultural co evolution
that are bound together
in ways that have gotten us to this point
and that if we're gonna get
to the next point that this kind of
cultivation, understanding, and harnessing
of the human imagination and in an even
more effective co evolutionary way
is probably the thing
that's gonna save our
you know behinds.
And so I think the work that you're doing
not only to look at how this works
to address neurological disorders
that we know are kind of
a real scourge of humanity
but what comes with humanity 2.0
is a kind of important thing.
So I think, do you have
another set of questions?
- I have some for Morris.
If you want to come.
So in terms of human evolution
and especially migration,
is the imagination always a positive force
and if so how does it come to be
overcoming in the process of considering
the fears from which the
first humans must have lived?
I think the question
is about if imagination
is always positive we have to first
conquer our fears to imagine
something in trial, right?
- I'm not sure if it's always positive
but what I was trying to say is that
no human society can continue
without or this would
be completely different.
If we didn't have this
level of social imagination.
Our society would be just
like that of the chimpanzees
where it's a matter of
interpersonal relationships
while the question for humans
is how you get beyond
interpersonal relationships
to get much bigger groups.
We see into personal
relationships in the end
limitless sizes of the groups
of the number of people you can have in
interpersonal relationships with obviously
so I don't think it's dangerous
the kind of societies would be produced
would be...
We probably wouldn't even recognize,
and we wouldn't get very far.
I always thought we would
have been wiped out years ago.
It'd be small and yeah.
- I have another one for you.
- Take the idea of
constructs of human grouping
and take it further.
Do you see ramifications towards
symbolic interactions
and towards structural
anthropogeny as direct consequences?
- Well I don't very much
like the term symbolic
and I could explain it in a simple way.
Several people have talked
about pretend playing
now it's very clear that in pretend play
children understand that it is pretend.
They love at the pretend
unlike Piaget who's just
sort of got muddled.
So children have this area
which they think is symbolic
but they're conscious of it not being true
on the other hand the kind of imagination
takes place when people think you know
their national identity or their clan
or objects almost like
mountains in the world.
They're not in a sense imaginary.
This seems to be completely different
and so the reason why I
don't like the term symbolic
is that it muddles these
two things together.
It muddles what we're
conscious of as a symbol
and what is probably much more important
we think of is just true.
- Alright, I think that's it.
(applause)
I would like to thank you
all for sticking around.
Do you have something to say?
- Before I thank everyone Caren Walker
wanted to correct
something briefly, brief.
- I do I do okay so I don't
know how many of you caught this
when you're standing
up here with the lights
and everything it's very disorienting.
So I was doing this
counterfactual reasoning
about my answer to your questions.
Somebody asked me about
neo natal imitation
which is way different
from pre natal imitation
which is the thing that I
actually answered about.
So neo natal imitation
is the thing that happens
after you're born where if you look at a
brand new baby and you
sticky your tongue out
they'll stick their tongue
out back at you, right?
This is a really different kind of thing
than the thing I thought
you were asking about.
So the question here is
that kind of imitation
is that somehow grounded in imagination
and I still don't know the answer
but it's sort of a
different work around answer
which is that neo natal imitation
we think of mostly as a social reflex,
it's something that happens
immediately after birth
and what it does is it
sort of paves the way
for all of the rest of social
cognition to come on board.
Attention to faces following gaze,
doing this kind of imitation
which makes your caregiver
love you a little bit more.
All of these things are really important
for fostering social connection
and so that later becomes complicated
things like theory of
mind which absolutely
involve imagining the
perspective of other people.
So anyway I would say
that neo natal imitation
is related to imagination but in a long
sort of long trajectory as
opposed to sort of immediate
so anyway I apologize
for my error, thank you.
- Thank you, very much.
(applause)
So with that I'd like to thank you all,
thank our two chairs, all our speakers,
the audience here and out in space.
And all the many people who have
continued supporting Carta,
I would invite you all to support Carta.
And I very much hope that we will
see you again at the upcoming symposia,
hopefully we'll see you
at some of these events
and again thank you all,
thank all the people for making possible
the recordings and the
streaming of this event.
(applause)
have a good one.
(upbeat music)